estuardo ahora Cómo calificar de estas
declaraciones y sobre todo Qué dice el
liderazgo del partido republicano el
hecho de que ella haya sido designada
para dar este discurso
Bueno mira el partido republicano a
través de los últimos cuatro años se ha
confiado en el liderazgo de Donald yo
creo que después de las elecciones del
medio término se dieron cuenta que el
liderazgo de Johnson no le sirve pero
siendo la portavoz de
esos últimos años
trabajó tuvo un papel muy importante en
avanzar las mentiras de el presente
Es triste que el partido republicano te
ha confiado en
un momento histórico donde estamos
viendo la manera de trabajar juntos
unificar el país y se haga justicia se
ha enfocado más que todo en avanzar una
política que dice que no hay que usar la
palabra
o sea eso cómo ayuda a los ciudadanos
decir que no se va a usar una palabra
que algunos de la comunidad latina creen
que es necesario para identificar a su
identidad no Es ridículo que
sea la portavoz del partido republicano
en un momento donde vemos que la
inversión Federal
la inversión Federal durante la pandemia
inversiones de de dinero histórico en
los Estados ahora vemos que Estados
republicanos tienen más dinero que nunca
porque el Gobierno Federal ha invertido
en sus estados para asegurar que esos
ciudadanos de cada cada República estado
republicano red States como lo dicen
tenga el dinero necesario para su
infraestructura para los exámenes de
covid para los servicios necesarios que
estamos viendo que Para apoyar los
negocios pequeños decir de que el estado
es algo independiente que no necesita de
del Gobierno Federal Es ridículo es no
entender el sistema de gobierno de
Estados Unidos
trabajamos acá juntos es cierto que cada
estado tiene su propio reglamento sus
propias leyes pero al nivel Federal hay
un marco donde tenemos que trabajar
juntos respetándonos mutuamente y
respetar el derecho de Cada ciudadano
que venga de Nueva York que venga de
Texas o de California Tenemos que
trabajar juntos y el mensaje del
presidente va a ir en esta noche es hay
que trabajar en la tradición de nuestro
gobierno y nuestra democracia que es
bipartidista ahora
seguir una una política de división está
bien pero nosotros vamos a llegar a la
final ganando y avanzando para cada
americano ser republicano o demócrata o
independiente Ese es el trabajo del
partido demócrata y lo vamos a